bonjour à toutes et tous je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver dans cette
nouvelle vidéo consacrée à marvel mais
avant d'entamer cette dernière je
voulais m'excuser auprès de groupes
il est vrai que la chaîne a pas mal
tourné au ralenti ces derniers temps et
je ne vous cache pas que mon moral était
vraiment au plus bas mais faire des
vidéos c'est vraiment un truc que
j'adore et il est temps que nous
reprenions de plus belle avec des
mystères tournant autour de marvel notre
sujet fétiche ou bien même star wars
strangers things etc n'hésitez
d'ailleurs vraiment pas à me proposer
vos idées de sujets en commentaire je
suis ouvert à tout on est ici pour
parler mystère de la pop culture
et je vous invite d'ailleurs à vous
réunir à nouveau dans la tribu du liana
heurte notre symbole de force et de
courage
et n'hésitez pas à vous abonner activer
la cloche on ne le rappellera jamais
assez mais c'est très important si vous
souhaitez être averti des nouvelles
vidéos allons maintenant dans le vif du
sujet bien que la communication de
marvel tourne autour du prochain film
black widow je pense qu'il est vraiment
intéressant de traiter de la série
falcon and the winter soldier prévu pour
cet été sur la plateforme disney plus
entre passage de flambeau retour de
personnages mythiques et menace de
l'ombre il ya vraiment des choses à dire
et qui méritent d'être mises en lumière
par rapport à ce que nous savons
actuellement la série tournera autour
des deux amis bucky barnes qui jouera
très probablement le rôle de mentors
envers le second personnage principal
faucon qui vient d'être nommé en
personne nouveau captain america par
steve rogers lui même les événements se
passeront suite à avengers endgame bien
évidemment et apparemment le baron zemo
serait de retour mais voilà seulement
tout ce que nous savons alors que
pourtant la série arrivera prochainement
et sera la première à inaugurer le
passage du marvel cinématiques unis
versent sur petit écran
concernant les mystères les
interrogations de l'oeuvre nous pouvons
nous interroger sur plusieurs choses et
notamment le rôle de captain america en
lui
m sam a été proclamé nouveau captain
america et pourtant la série s'appelle
falcon and the winter soldier sam n'est
toujours pas considéré comme le nouveau
captain dans la série et possède
toujours son ancien nom ce n'est pas
très étonnant
ça me va devoir faire ses preuves et
devenir une icône un héros de la nation
et la tâche va être rude
effectivement même si steve lui a passé
le flambeau
ou plutôt de boucliers cela ne veut pas
dire que sam sera accepté directement et
bien au contraire
steve a été le héros de plusieurs
générations et a marqué à de nombreuses
reprises les esprits le peuple aura du
mal à faire la transition et ça me va
devoir regagner leur confiance et en
popularité
ce dernier est plus jeunes moins
expérimentés moins mature et surtout
moins puissants car il n'a pas le sérum
du super-soldat faut qu'on va devoir
travailler sur lui même et accepter la
critique juste comme injuste et je pense
que ce sera un arc important de la série
après tout sur le court teaser que nous
avait présenté marvel nous voyons une
foule en délire acclamant un captain
america en tout cas il va devoir faire
ses preuves et bugs qui sera justement
là pour l'épauler
et oui on en parle peu mais bucky sera
bel et bien présent pour faucons mais
même si les deux amis s'apprécient
beaucoup le rôle de bucky est avant tout
d'accompagner le choix qu'a fait steve
est de former le jeune capitaine
néanmoins une deuxième raison a le
mérite d'exister
effectivement les deux personnages
pourraient être la poursuite du baron
zemo d'après certaines rumeurs
personnage qui s'est servi du soldat de
l'hiver pour arriver à ses fins lors des
événements de civil war
connaissant la dangerosité du personnage
et notamment pour tout ce que ce dernier
lui a fait il est possible que bucky
souhaite tout simplement se venger de
cet ancien ennemi et ce serait pourquoi
il le traqueraient permettant à faucons
de se former dans cette quête
mais le rôle du baron zemo est vraiment
le plus gros point d'interrogation de la
série zemo sera de retour avec son
accoutrement traditionnel des comics
genre son célèbre masque violet
néanmoins
ce dernier a énormément été modifié par
rapport aux comics par exemple dans les
comics il existe deux bars ont connu le
père et le fils le père et est actif
durant toute la période de la seconde
guerre mondiale était un ennemi de
captain america soit steve rogers mais
avec le mc eu toute cette partie a été
effacée et baron zemo fils celui que
nous connaissons possède donc des
intentions différentes soit dans civil
war venger sa famille morte durant les
événements de l'aso covi et non venger
son père comme dans les comics
grossièrement parlant c'est ça ce qui
est très intéressant et mystérieux et
que le baron voulait se venger des
vengeurs en les détruisant de
l'intérieur vous vous souvenez de la
célèbre scène où tony découvre la vérité
sur la mort de ses parents civil war
aura définitivement brisé quelque chose
entre le héros et le baron a entre
guillemets et gagner au point même que
sa mission accomplie ce dernier décide
de sauter la vie mecha la alias le black
panthères l'en empêchera juste avant
s'étant défait de tous et sentiment de
trahison
le mystère se retrouve donc ici le baron
a voulu se suicider car sa mission était
accomplie et n'avait plus de raison de
vivre puisque c'était simplement pour
venger sa famille bucky était un
instrument pour justement confronté
steve et tony néanmoins à l'heure de
falcon and the winter soldier tony nous
a maintenant quitté et steve pareil
entre guillemets au vu de comment le
personnage a été traitée dans spider man
far from home
alors le fait que baron zemo soit un
ennemi de bucky et de sam me fait
réellement douter car techniquement il
n'a rien fait de spécial contre eux et
pourrait même peut-être qui sait
s'allier à eux dans leur quête
le problème étant que le baron
souhaitait se supprimer alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui sortir son masque et croquer
à pleines dents le rôle de son
personnage il est clair que la série ne
tournera pas autour de gros super
pouvoirs cosmiques
en tout genre après les événements des
jam le mca a besoin de se re stabiliser
et nous relancer dans une nouv
r sam et bleu qui sont de grands héros
mais reste des terriens et surtout sam
doit se former
il est évident que leurs ennemis seront
à peu près du même type et non des gros
extraterrestre avec des pierres d'un
film le mc hu doit rester cohérent du
coup il est fort c'est que le baron zemo
restera à peu près le même que celui que
nous avons eues dans civil war en tout
cas il se pourrait que zemo travail pour
thunderbolt
ross à personnage très secondaire mais
que nous avons vu à plusieurs reprises
et notamment dans six villes voir avec
les accords de sault kobe il est clair
que la série va nous amener des
révélations et que thunderbolt ne porte
pas les héros dans son coeur et aimerait
justement s'en servir comme des outils
c'est ce qui semble d'ailleurs se
prononcer avec le film de black widow
qui aura tout perdu après six mille
voire entre familles des avengers et son
amour pour banner thunderbolt va très
certainement profiter il se pourrait que
des mots depuis le début agissait pour
lui et se salissent les mains à sa place
pour justement mettre en place les
accords de soko vie et avoir les pleins
pouvoirs sur eux
enfin nous devons parler de steve si
steve a réécrit l'histoire du mc eu avec
son voyage temporel il se peut que ce
dernier combattu heinrich des mots le
père durant le moment où le premier
steve était congelé c'est une idée qui
est totalement farfelu et qui provient
100% de moi mais si les scénaristes
veulent vraiment intégré le baron zemo
côté comics avec son masque peut être
qu'un récit autour de steve retourner
dans le passé serait mise en lumière
après tout c'est compliqué de penser que
steve et jouer le mari modèle sans rien
faire pendant plus de 70 ans alors qu'il
est un héros qui ne peut s'empêcher
d'agir pour au truc
et puis il paye elle-même fonctionnement
donc c'est un petit peu étrange stop
petite pause et petit disclaimer je sais
que le père du baron zemo est mort
pendant les événements de la sauque ovi
mail steve en retournant dans le passé a
donc réécrit l'histoire en quelque sorte
cela pourrait faire l'objet d'une
prochaine vidéo mais cela veut dire que
quand le steve originel est prisonnier
de la glace
celui d'anne games est en train de faire
sa vie avec peggy et c'est à ce moment
que l'histoire avec le père heinrich ses
mots a pu se faire vu que normalement
steve est prisonnier de la glace
enfin bref ce n'est qu'une simple
supposition voir un peu folle retour à
la vidéo mais je serais très content de
revoir steve ce dernier est toujours en
vie après une game
il est presque quasiment sûr que ça mais
vu qu'ils retourneront le voir à
plusieurs reprises comme un sage leur
permettant de trouver la voie surtout
pour sam qui va devoir faire ses preuves
et prendre ses responsabilités en tant
que capitaine la prise du rôle sera très
certainement la conclusion de la série
d'ailleurs
enfin voila merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo cela faisait un moment que
je souhaitais en reparler de marvel et
c'est loin d'être la dernière vidéo
si ce que je viens de vous présenter
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me soutenir
avec un pouce bleus et aussi à vous
abonner pour ne rien louper des
prochaines vidéos l'année 2020 ne fait
que commencer et nous avons plein de
mystères à traiter ensemble
prenez soin de vos proches est resté
bien chez vous au vu des circonstances
actuelles
j'espère pouvoir vous divertir et vous
faire réfléchir le temps du confinement
que le liner soit avec vous les amis à
très bientôt
[Musique]